Vsauce Kevin here possessed witches but
devil dancing crazed laughter and a TV
show that actually made people sick it's
not fiction it's mass hysteria clinical
mass hysteria describes the spread of a
psychologically manifested illness one
or two people show signs of illness that
they blame on poison gas
genies or a ghost and suddenly others
begin to show the same symptoms or worse
mass hysteria typically occurs in
high-stress situations among people in
confined areas like schools factories or
a small village in colonial
Massachusetts I get it
mass hysteria colonial Massachusetts
it's very funny
thanks hey Mike from idea channel here
Kevin do you mind if I sure go right
ahead thanks man
the Salem witch trials of 1692 were a
catastrophic overreaction to mass
psychogenic illness two young girls
began having fits of screaming and
contortions symptoms that commonly
accompanied mass psychogenic illness
which spread to other girls in the Salem
Village the town's verdict was that the
devil had turned the girls into witches
and panic consumed the villagers until
twenty people were tried and executed
modern theories for what caused the
first two girls symptoms range from
eating rye bread infected with fungus to
contracting a bird borne encephalitis
lethargica doctors found no evidence of
injuries or explanations for the girl's
behavior and in the absence of a
scientific reason the occult filled the
gap and what ensued was quite literally
a which one the bodies of over 400
people in Strasbourg France were
infected by a plague of dancing in 1518
during a time of extreme famine a woman
began dancing in the middle of the
street and by the end of the month
hundreds more had been consumed by the
trance officials believe the afflicted
had to dance the
thickness out of their systems so
musicians were hired to keep them moving
and guild halls were dedicated to the
frenzied dancing dozens died from
exhaustion strokes and heart attacks and
eventually the surviving dancers were
loaded onto wagons and taken to a shrine
to beg for mercy Europe experienced
dozens of dance plagues throughout the
Renaissance with southern Italy seeing
such an uptick in possessed dancing that
they blamed it on tarantula bites a
syndrome fittingly dubbed Durrant ISM
laughter might be the best medicine but
it can also be part of the disease in
1962 several villages in what is now
Tanzania couldn't stop laughing three
girls at a boarding school started
laughing uncontrollably and it spread
throughout the school forcing it to
close the girls returned home where the
laughter spreads to their neighbours and
then to nearby villages eventually
affecting thousands of people of course
it's physically impossible to laugh
continually for days due to the strain
on respiration with the current world
record for longest laughter clocking in
at just three hours and six minutes the
afflicted separated their bouts of
laughter with crying fainting and
exclamations of pain from rashes and
rashes are never funny mass hysteria
continues today in 2006 an episode of a
popular teen soap opera in portugal
called strawberries with sugar caused
over 300 students from 14 schools to
develop symptoms depicted by characters
on the show the dizziness and difficulty
breathing forced some of the schools to
close due to what's now referred to as
the strawberries with sugar virus which
coincided with student stress over five
Oleg slams don't you mean final exams
yeah what I said you said viable exams
finalists
those aren't words those are hard haha
and as always thanks for watching
special thanks to Mike from PBS idea
channel for helping me out yeah man
thanks for having me
and all this talk of mass hysteria might
make you wonder how it is that people
start to believe these kinds of things
and it has a lot to do with proof which
we're gonna go talk about over on idea
channel right now so let's check it out
and while you're there make sure you
subscribe
you